[Music]
the ideal scp participant
is someone who has been courageous in
the past
to approach challenges and opportunities
in new ways
and brave enough today to move forward
to even greater things
stanford is leveraging the academia and
the business
and bringing together a very diverse set
of people
to give a rich learning experience it
really is the distillation
of the most important components
of leadership the professors from day
one
what i was struck with was how real and
how relatable they were
no barrier scp flex
is a different option for the stanford
executive program
instead of coming to stanford for six
immersive weeks in person
you come for two weeks immerse yourself
engage
and then you go back to your home base
and for a period while you're back at
work we
engage in online synchronous delivery of
content where you're
interacting with the faculty interacting
with your other colleagues in the
program
as well as engaging in networking events
and leadership coaching
innovation growth how to transform
into the 21st century economy these are
the topics that the stanford business
school
faculty are the leading researchers on
those faculty
will be your professors in both sep
full-time
and sap flex your job is to come here
not because you know what's next but
because you want to design
a future of discovery beyond your
wildest dreams
it is a lot of connections that can help
you think
through what you're going to do next
adding all those elements into the
program make this
really life-changing